Next, we're going to travel all the way to Baltimore to
the Johns Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public Health,
to speak with Dr. Gerard Anderson,
a professor there and the first author of
the paper I cite more than any other during this course,
"The Rising Tide of Chronic Disease in America."
Well Gerard, thank you so much for being with us today.
It's a thrill to meet you.
I'm glad to be here.
Great. A decade ago,
you and your colleague Jane Horvath,
published what I view as a seminal paper,
"The Growing Burden of Chronic Disease in America."
The students of the course,
if they've been paying attention are quite familiar with it by now.
And it opened my mind to the aggregate problem of chronic disease,
in a way that really no previous paper had done.
Which is why I view it the way I do.
So we're 10 years later.
Have we made progress? Where are we?
Well, we have made progress.
I mean I think what you knew already is that,
as you saw patients that had chronic disease,
but you didn't know how many patients there were,
and now we know that there are 150 million Americans,
almost one out of every two Americans that have one or more chronic conditions.
And that is sort of the new information that we were trying to bring 10 years ago.
Now what we're trying to do,
now that we have the attention of the policymakers,
is to start changing the delivery system.
That starts with prevention,
but it goes to care and cure for
these chronic conditions and there we're making a lot less progress.
I was more optimistic 10 years ago than I am now.
Most everything that we've tried recently has just not worked very well.
Well, here in the last few years,
we've tried to make the healthcare industry adopt health IT,
and we've tried to create health information exchanges.
We're still really early in that.
But are you optimistic that that will happen and that it will make a difference.
Well, it is happening,
so I'm very optimistic that it will happen.
What I don't think we've solved very well so far,
is that dashboard problem of a doctor.
I have 10 minutes to take care of a patient,
and she has seven things wrong with her,
she's seeing nine other doctors and I have 10 minutes.
If I spend most of that time looking at her medical record,
I now have five minutes to talk to her.
And so the challenge is,
how can we get that information out to
the physician in a timely fashion for that complex patient?
For the patient who only has diabetes, it's pretty easy.
But for that patient, who has diabetes and
congestive heart failure and beginning Alzheimer's and arthritis,
and is seeing all these different doctors,
and taking lots of different medications, that's the challenge.
I hope the students remember that comment because that's
basically what we're going to talk about in lesson six of the course.
Great.
Well, you also mentioned incentives.
I mean clearly the healthcare system has never been incented.
Do you see that working?
Are you optimistic that that's actually going to happen in
this endlessly complex adaptive health care system?
So, I was just amazed when I started this work in the 1990s,
that Australia had tried care coordination programs and they had and all failed.
And then I said,
but the United States can do it differently or the UK could do it differently.
And so I've been looking around the world for those models,
and I just don't see them yet.
I mean, it's just sort of,
we know what we need to do which is to get everybody on the same team,
probably with a nurse practitioner talking to all the doctors,
but we haven't been able to figure it out.
So most all of the demonstrations that we've tried,
both in the public sector and the private sector,
just haven't been able to save money,
reduce, improve outcomes, and improve satisfaction.
We just don't have very many of those things that hit all three of them very well.
And we're still working and so I'm optimistic that we will find it,
but so far, we just haven't been very successful.
Well, your paper actually ends on an optimistic note.
You point to the re-engineering the healthcare system a century ago,
around new knowledge in public health.
Is it so fundamentally different now that that optimism may be misplaced?
No, but I think if you read it a little more carefully,
what you'll see is I said,
we moved in 50 years from a system
oriented around infectious disease to one that's oriented on acute illnesses.
And then we got that done by about 2000.
And I said, it is going to take us 50 years to
reorient the healthcare system around chronic disease.
We have to start with the evidence base,
we have to know how to take care of somebody who has seven things wrong with her,
when the NIH and the FDA exclude all those people from clinical trials.
We don't have the educational system and the medical schools oriented around that.
We don't have the financing,
and so right now,
there isn't a real strong incentive for
hospitals and doctors to really go after these people,
to take care of them in an effective way.
In fact, because they don't know how to do it,
they want to run away from them in most cases.
But this is where the money is.
Two-thirds of Medicare spending is by people with five or more chronic conditions.
We've got to get the system right for these people,
we just don't know how to do it yet.
So, I can't speak to 50 years ago,
but 40 years ago,
I was a medical student.
First getting interested in this.
And I remember going to meetings,
and they would say, well here's where we are,
and if these trends continue and we don't do anything by right about now,
health care will be consuming 20% of the gross domestic product,
a number that's absolutely not sustainable.
Right.
Now I've seen projections from OMB and others,
that if we don't do anything it will be 40% in 50 years.
Do we have 50 years?
Well, when I started working and trying to
control health care costs in the 1970s, I said,
we'll never be able to sustain 10% of GDP on healthcare,
now it's close to 20.
So, I've stopped making projections as to whether or not we can afford to do something.
What we know is that by the time it gets to almost 30%,
which isn't that far along,
almost all the growth in the economy,
all the productivity growth in the economy will in
fact go to support the growth in healthcare,
and that's probably not sustainable.
But we don't know what's going to turn the ship around,
maybe it's IT, maybe it's changing the financial incentives,
but since everybody is making so much money in healthcare, and you know,
jobs are important and financial security is important,
it's going to be a really tough change.
So many of us speculate that eventually with our backs against the wall,
we'll adopt a single payer system like every other country on earth.
You think that's going to happen here in the US?
I was more optimistic in the 90s than I am today.
Basically, Americans love choice.
All you have to do is go to a grocery store and go down the cereal aisle and
look at 40 to 100 different choices of cereal,
whereas if you go to France,
you'll see two or three in most cases.
Choice is what makes America,
and is going to be really hard to get the private insurance industry out of it.
We can't even get right now,
many of the states, to embrace Medicaid,
so if they can't embrace Medicaid which is free money to them,
why would we think that they would go to a single payer?
I mean, I think it makes sense.
It means that we pay a lot more for healthcare
than other industrialized countries because of this choice,
but America seems to really like choice.
Well, thank you very much.
It's been a pleasure.
Thank you.
Maybe we'll be able to get together 10 more years and see what's happened.
I hopefully it will be more optimistic that time.